Oh yeah, so what are we going to call that episode? This is going to be cut into like three episodes and we're naming an episode that people have listened to two episodes ago. I don't know. I mean, Skynet maybe? Skynet is here. Skynet is here. Skynet is here.
哦，是的，那我们要把那一集叫什么名字呢？这一集要被剪成大约三集，我们要给一个大家在两集前就已经听过的节目起名字。我不知道。我是说，天网（Skynet）也许？天网来了。天网来了。天网来了。
Yeah, I think that's got to be the name. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 35 recorded on June 30th, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, of, of, uh, of comedy gems prior to, uh, to your joining that are on my opacity. Okay. We will, I will have fun listening to those. But hang on. I want to see the, did you get it? No, no, no. So my, my haircut's at 205, uh, which is.
是的，我想那一定得是这个名字。欢迎收看 ADSP 播客第 35 期，录制于 2021 年 6 月 30 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起，在，呃，在，呃，在你加入之前的一些喜剧珍品，都在我的不透明度上。好吧。我听那些会觉得很有趣的。但是等等。我想看看，你拿到了吗？不，不，不。所以我的，我的理发时间是 2:05，呃，也就是。
Oh, that's right. It's, it's after today. Well, okay. Then I still want to see your hair because it's going to be the last time I get to see it super long before you go back to regular Connor hair. So turn your camera on. Yeah, my camera is on.
哦，对了。这是，是在今天之后。好吧，好吧，那我还是想看你的头发，因为这将是我最后一次看到你留超级长的头发，然后你就要变回普通的康纳发型了。所以把你的摄像头打开。对，我的摄像头开着呢。
So I'm in Edge right now because Chrome is just like I can click on the Google Meet thing and then the screen is frozen. So I think this one's using the camera so it won't let edge so now if i do that hey there we go hey there you are well it sounds like you need a new computer uh or a new browser i probably do something i probably do need a um just making sure, yes, I am recording. All right, we're good to go.
所以我现在在用 Edge，因为 Chrome 就好像我点击 Google Meet 的那个东西然后屏幕就冻结了。所以我认为这个正在使用摄像头，所以它不允许 Edge，所以现在如果我这样做，嘿，我们走吧，嘿，你在这儿。好吧，听起来你需要一台新电脑，呃，或者一个新浏览器。我可能确实需要一个，呃，我可能确实需要一个，呃，只是确认一下，是的，我在录音。好了，我们准备好了。
Yes, I probably do need a new computer. This laptop is, ooh, 2017. My laptop's 2017. It works perfectly fine. I have a Lenovo 25-year anniversary edition, which is like a limited series run. What brand did you say? It's Lenovo. Oh, I thought you said Lenova, and I was like. I series run. What brand did you say? It's Lenovo. Oh, I thought you said Lenova.
是的，我可能确实需要一台新电脑。这台笔记本电脑是，哦，2017 年的。我的笔记本电脑是 2017 年的。它工作得非常好。我有一台联想 25 周年纪念版，这是一个限量系列。你刚刚说的是什么牌子？是联想（Lenovo）。哦，我还以为你说是 Lenova，我想……系列运行。你刚刚说的是什么牌子？是联想。哦，我还以为你说是 Lenova。
I might have said Lenova. That's not how that company is pronounced. Although that company doesn't exist anymore. Didn't they get acquired by IBM or something? No, you are... The ThinkPad division of IBM, which made great laptops, was sold to Lenovo. Not a. Lenovo.
我可能说的是 Lenova。那可不是那个公司的发音方式。尽管那家公司已经不存在了。它们不是被 IBM 收购了什么的吗？不，你…… IBM 的 ThinkPad 部门，以前生产过很棒的笔记本电脑，被卖给了联想。不是 A。联想。
And I made a 25-year anniversary edition ThinkPad, which has the classic ThinkPad keyboard. And I bought one. And I'm quite happy with it. That's good. They've got that little uh track thingy red dot in the middle yes it does yes it does it's got my trackball you're very excited about it not only at the trackball that when they ship it to you they ship you they shipped you the different trackball heads from all the different eras of thinkpads so that you could use whichever one you wanted why are you so excited about it and all the different eras of ThinkPad so that you could use whichever one you wanted.
我制作了一个 25 周年纪念版的 ThinkPad，它拥有经典的 ThinkPad 键盘。我买了一个。我对此相当满意。那很好。它们有那个小小的，呃，中间有红点的追踪小玩意，是的，确实有，确实有，它有我的轨迹球，你对此非常兴奋，不仅有轨迹球，当他们把它发货给你时，他们还发给你了，他们发给了你来自不同时代 ThinkPad 的不同轨迹球头，以便你可以使用你想要的任何一个，为什么你对它这么兴奋，以及来自不同时代 ThinkPad 的所有不同版本，以便你可以使用你想要的任何一个。
Why are you so excited about it and all the different versions that you got? Nostalgia, man, nostalgia. How can you not be excited about nostalgia? Those good old school ThinkPads, those are good laptops. They could physically beat up other laptops. I'm not sure that's a good thing. Did you use the little, what is it called?
你为什么对它以及你得到的所有不同版本这么兴奋？情怀，老兄，情怀。你怎么能不为情怀感到兴奋呢？那些优秀的老派 ThinkPad，它们是很好的笔记本电脑。它们在物理上可以打败其他笔记本电脑。我不确定这算不算是一件好事。你用过那个小的，叫什么来着？
Trackball versus a touchpad? Oh, yeah. Well, because the Lenovo ThinkPad W510 that I've used for most of my career, it is on its second screen. And at some point during the course of the many times that I've opened that sucker up, I think I did something to the mouse pad that caught the long story short, the mouse pad no longer works. Only the trackball works. So yeah, I'm pretty familiar with it. That's one way to learn. One way to learn. Break the touchpad. So what do you think about this GitHub co-pilot thing? I don't even know. What is this?
轨迹球还是触控板？哦，是的。嗯，因为我整个职业生涯大部分时间都在使用的联想 ThinkPad W510，它正在使用它的第二个屏幕。在打开那个吸盘的很多次中的某次过程中，我想我对鼠标垫做了一些事情，导致了长话短说，鼠标垫不再工作了。只有轨迹球还能工作。所以，是的，我对它非常熟悉。这也是一种学习方式。一种学习方式。把触控板弄坏。那么，你对这个 GitHub Copilot 有什么看法？我都不知道。这是什么？
Do you live under a rock? Are you not on Twitter 24-7 like I am? I mean, I use GitHub for my day job. So if there's something that happened to github I thought I would definitely audience you are you're in for a treat because Connor is about to get exposed to github co-pilot um for the first time live on this podcast I am going to send you the link and then I'm just gonna I'm just gonna sit wait where's the chat thingy
你难道是山顶洞人吗？你难道不像我一样 24 小时刷 Twitter 吗？我的意思是，我日常工作使用 GitHub。所以如果 GitHub 发生了什么事，我想我肯定会……听众朋友们，你们有福了，因为康纳即将在这个播客上首次被曝光 GitHub Copilot……活生生地，我一会儿把链接发给你，然后我，我只管坐着，等等，聊天窗口在哪儿？
Google keeps on changing there we're recording this in Google Meet you know what I think maybe we're done with Google Meet I think maybe the fact that your laptop can no longer join it and that I cannot find the chat thing. All right.
谷歌一直在变，我们在 Google Meet 里录制这个，你知道吗，也许我们该放弃 Google Meet 了。我想也许是因为你的笔记本电脑再也无法加入它，而且我也找不到聊天窗口了。好吧。
I just Twitter DM'd you the link. God, you know, I liked it back in the day when the way that you communicated with everybody was text message. Whereas like today, like I have one group of friends that communicates with me over Twitter DMs. That's probably most people. Then I got another group that does it over Slack, another group that does it over Discord. Then Hana uses Facebook Messenger with me. That's the only person that I use Facebook Messenger with,
我刚通过 Twitter 私信把链接发给你了。天哪，你知道的，我挺喜欢以前大家通过短信和所有人沟通的日子。而像今天，我有的一群朋友通过 Twitter 私信和我沟通。这可能是大多数人。然后我还有另一群人通过 Slack 沟通，另一群通过 Discord。然后哈娜（Hana）和我用 Facebook Messenger。那是唯一一个我使用 Facebook Messenger 的人，
which is a little bit convenient because if I get a Facebook Messenger notification, I know that it's Hana. And then I got two people that use signal and like one person that uses whatsapp it's just like it's too many things it's too many things all right all right are you looking at this i literally have to go to my phone because like chrome i don't know what chrome is doing but chrome uh did oh yeah i sent you a link your ai pair programmer. Yeah. Yeah. So for those who are listening, GitHub Copilot is... Is this a joke?
这其实挺方便的，因为如果我收到 Facebook Messenger 的通知，我就知道是哈娜。然后我有两个人用 Signal，还有一个人用 WhatsApp，就好像是，这东西太多了，这东西太多了。好吧，好吧，你在看这个吗？我真的得用手机，因为 Chrome，我不知道 Chrome 在干什么，但 Chrome，哦，对了，我给你发了一个链接，你的 AI 编程助手。对。对。所以对于听众朋友们，GitHub Copilot 是……这是一个笑话吗？
It is not a joke. It is not a joke. It is a very real thing. GitHub Copilot is an AI that suggests code for you while you're typing out code. I haven't tried it out yet. I'm just hating on it on the internet,
这不是一个笑话。这不是一个笑话。这是一个非常真实的东西。GitHub Copilot 是一个在你编写代码时为你推荐代码的人工智能。我还没试过呢。我只是在互联网上对它进行口诛笔伐，
so I don't know much about it, but the little examples on their website show you type out a comment or you start typing out the signature for a function, and it does its AI magic and goes and figures out what the function should be based on that. I don't,
所以我对它了解不多，但他们网站上的那些小例子显示，你打出一个注释或者开始打出一个函数的签名，它就会施展其 AI 魔法，并根据这些去弄清楚这个函数应该是什么样的。我不知道，
uh, this seems like, uh, this seems like a, could be going, could go terribly wrong. Uh, like what is this based on?
呃，这看起来像是个，这看起来像是个，可能会变得，可能会变得一团糟。呃，就像这是基于什么？
Is this based on stack overflow or like, no, it's, no, that's the, that's the best part. It's trained on code on GitHub And they say in their disclaimer
这是基于 Stack Overflow 还是像，不，它，不，那是，那是最好的部分。它是基于 GitHub 上的代码训练的。并且他们在免责声明中说
That it's trained on this large database of code And that usually it won't do this But sometimes it will suggest A snippet of code That is exactly taken from some of the code That it was trained on. And so people on Twitter very rapidly figured out, oh, hey, what are the licensing implications of that? If your AI pair programmer suggests some GPL licensed code, like, is your code now gpl licensed so yeah this is uh yeah i feel like they you know
它是基于这个大型代码数据库进行训练的，通常它不会这样做，但有时它会推荐一个完全取自它所训练的一些代码的代码片段。所以 Twitter 上的用户很快就反应过来了，哦，嘿，这有什么开源许可的影响吗？如果你的 AI 编程助手推荐了一些采用 GPL 许可的代码，那么你的代码现在也是 GPL 许可的吗？所以，是的，这，呃，是的，我觉得他们，你知道，
they talk about you know biased algorithms which is really just biased data and like this seems like it's just gonna i feel like there's probably more bad code on github than there is good code i feel like and i i can say that because i have a lot of garbage code that I put on GitHub that I'm just like, oh, we need to put this somewhere. It's just, you know, the world doesn't need to see it, but I need to put this somewhere and it's going to go on GitHub. And if you look at some of the code that I put on from years ago, it's just awful. I think Odin Holmes too, he, in one of his talks mentions that like all of the code on
他们谈论有偏见的算法，这实际上只是有偏见的数据，而且这看起来就像是，我觉得 GitHub 上的烂代码可能比好代码还要多，我觉得是这样的，我可以这么说，因为我有很多垃圾代码放在 GitHub 上，我当时就想，哦，我们需要把这个放在某个地方。这只是，你知道，世界不需要看到它，但我需要把这个放在某个地方，它就要去 GitHub。如果你看看我多年前放上去的一些代码，那简直糟透了。我想奥丁·霍姆斯（Odin Holmes）也是，他在他的一个演讲中提到，他 GitHub 上的所有代码
his GitHub is just awful. Oh, yeah. I have code on my GitHub from like 2011 when I was a little squirt. And like that code is. Yeah, that's that's rough. That is rough code. Yeah. So like this, it just seems like a terrible, a terrible idea.
都只是糟透了。哦，是的。我 GitHub 上有来自 2011 年的代码，当时我还是个乳臭未干的小毛孩。那代码简直……是的，那是很粗糙的代码。那是非常粗糙的代码。是的。所以就像这样，这看起来真是一个糟糕的主意，一个糟糕的主意。
It's like, where could we find some really low quality code and let's train train our ai to write code like that it gets better the one of the examples on their like launch page um shows an example of a function that is dealing with quantities of money and it's using floating point numbers to represent quantities of money and it's using floating point numbers to represent quantities of money for those for those who may be unfamiliar uh floating point is not a uh is not a suitable data type to store quantities of money because um floating point can lose you know it can start to lose information and like the last thing you want is to lose a few cents it when you're uh uh computing financial transactions because it may not seem like much but like over time it starts adding up and then uh and then like bad things happen they've got little uh what do they call them um testimonials github co-pilot
这就像是，我们在哪里可以找到一些真正低质量的代码，然后让我们训练我们的 AI 来写这样的代码。它变得越来越好。他们发布页面上的其中一个例子，展示了一个处理金钱数量的函数的例子，它使用浮点数来表示金钱数量，它使用浮点数来表示金钱数量。对于那些可能不熟悉的人来说，呃，浮点数不是一个，不是一个适合存储金钱数量的数据类型，因为，呃，浮点数会丢失，你知道它会开始丢失信息，而且你最不想看到的就是在计算金融交易时损失几分钱，因为这看起来可能不算什么，但随着时间的推移，它开始累积，然后，呃，然后就会发生糟糕的事情。他们有一些，呃，他们叫它们什么，呃，用户证言。GitHub Copilot
discovered that a test file i was working on was missing a specific test and suggested and wrote the test for me what that doesn't sound right like you were just in a file and then Copilot was like, hey, are you missing this test? I wrote it. Like, that doesn't, something doesn't add up here. I, what day is it? Maybe it's not an AI. Maybe it's actually just some guy in a room. I'm impressed by how GitHub Copilot seems to know exactly what I want to type next.
发现我正在处理的一个测试文件缺少一个特定的测试，并为我建议并编写了测试。什么？这听起来不对，就像你当时正在一个文件中，然后 Copilot 就说，嘿，你漏了这个测试吗？我写好了。这听起来，有些地方不对劲。我，今天是几号？也许它不是 AI。也许它实际上只是房间里的某个人。我印象深刻的是 GitHub Copilot 似乎确切地知道我想接着打什么。
Well, that's concerning. That's not impressive. We've got a problem here. You should be checking the back of your neck to see if you got something plugged into you, man. Somebody wrote somewhere something to the effect of, well, at least the rise of Skynet will be well documented. Skynet is a reference to the general artificial intelligence in the Terminator series of movies that destroys a large chunk of humanity by launching all the nukes
嗯，这有点令人担忧。这并不令人印象深刻。我们这里有个问题。你得检查一下你的后颈，看看是不是有什么东西插在你身上，老兄。某人在某处写了一些类似于“好吧，至少天网的崛起将被很好地记录下来”的话。天网是指《终结者》系列电影中的通用人工智能，它通过发射所有的核弹摧毁了人类的大部分，
and then tries to destroy the rest of humanity by sending Arnold Schwarzenegger back in time to kill some people from the 80s. The 3% of our audience that didn't know appreciates that explanation. Although, what percentage of our audience do you think actually doesn't know what Skynet is? Well, so, you know, I think that it's always important to give context and to not make assumptions about what people know. One of the places where this comes up so frequently for me is acronyms. And I'm super bold about it. TLAs?
然后试图通过把阿诺德·施瓦辛格（Arnold Schwarzenegger）送回过去杀死 20 世纪 80 年代的一些人来消灭剩下的人类。我们那 3% 不知道这一点的听众很感激这个解释。尽管，你认为我们的听众中究竟有多少百分比实际上不知道什么是天网？嗯，所以，你知道，我认为提供背景知识并且不要对人们了解的内容做假设总是很重要的。这种情况对我来说经常发生的一个地方就是缩写。我对此非常大胆。TLA（三字母缩写）？
Yeah, TLA. So there's a great story. One of the people that Connor that um that connor works with mark harris um mark has been at nvidia for um oh for many years well over a decade maybe close to two decades yeah it's like 17 or 18 he's he was one of the people responsible for popularizing CUDA and wrote a lot of literature about it. Coined to the term GPGPU, actually. Yeah, he did. And when I started at NVIDIA, him and I had an interaction. We were talking about something. And I sent him an email and I said, well, what about UVM? UVM stands for Unified Virtual Memory, which is like the internal acronym for what we call CUDA Unified Memory. And he sent me back an email that just said,
是的，TLA。所以有一个很棒的故事。康纳的一位，呃，康纳的同事马克·哈里斯（Mark Harris），马克在英伟达（Nvidia）工作了，呃，很多年，远超十年，可能接近二十年。是的，大约 17 或 18 年。他是负责普及 CUDA 并为此撰写了大量文献的人之一。实际上，他还创造了 GPGPU 这个词。是的，他确实创造了。当我刚开始在英伟达工作时，我和他有过一次交流。我们在谈论一些事情。我给他发了一封电子邮件，我说，那么 UVM 呢？UVM 代表统一虚拟内存（Unified Virtual Memory），这就像是我们所说的 CUDA 统一内存的内部缩写。他回给我一封电子邮件，上面只写着：
you shouldn't use TLAs. And I sent him an email saying, what is TLA? And he sent me back an email that simply said three-letter acronym. And I just, that was just it. I was just like, wow, you got me. You got me good. So if somebody uses an acronym on Twitter or something, like I'm pretty bold about like, I'll just go and ask them. Like I was reading a twed, a twed, a thread.
你不应该使用 TLA。我给他回了一封邮件，说什么是 TLA？他回给我一封邮件，上面简单写着：三字母缩写（three-letter acronym）。我当时就，就只是这样。我当时就想，哇，你把我问倒了。你把我问得好惨。所以如果有人在 Twitter 或其他地方使用了缩写，我很勇敢，我会直接去问他们。就像我当时在读一篇 twed，一篇 twed，一个 thread（帖子）。
Lenovo and a twed. A thread from somebody. And they used the acronym TC. And I was like, I don't, I don't know what TC is. I think there's like a TC39, which is maybe some JavaScript committee. And to me, TC and the isosense can mean technical committee, but I'm like, that's not what they mean. So I'm like, I better ask, and I just asked.
Lenovo 和一个 twed。来自某人的 thread。他们使用了缩写 TC。我就想，我，我不知道 TC 是什么。我想好像有个 TC39，那可能是某个 JavaScript 委员会。对我来说，TC 在 ISO 意义上可以指技术委员会（technical committee），但我觉得这不是他们的意思。所以我宁愿问一下，我就问了。
They meant total compensation. But it was just like, and I get it. It's a tweet. You've got a limited number of characters. You've got to abbreviate sometimes. And so I don't fault anybody for for that but um but yeah acronyms acronyms are not my favorite thing you'll notice that i i go out of my way to avoid saying luge which is the name of the c++ committee's library evolution group i instead say library evolution
他们的意思是总补偿（total compensation）。但这就像是，我懂的。这是一条推文。你的字符数有限。有时你必须缩写。所以我并不因此责怪任何人，但是，但是，是的，缩写不是我的最爱。你会注意到我刻意避免说 luge，这是 C++ 委员会的库演变小组（library evolution group）的名字，我代之以说库演变（library evolution），
because lug is a term that you only understand library evolution working group is what it stands for. You only understand that acronym if like you're on the committee. And likewise, like I'm not a big fan of, I'm not a big fan of the degree to which the C++ committee uses esoteric numbers for things. Somebody will be like, oh, well, we should ask SG16 what that is. And if you're not on the C++ committee, SG16 does not have meaning to you.
因为 lug 是一个你只有……库演变工作组（library evolution working group）是它的全称。你只有在委员会里才会理解那个缩写。同样地，我也不是很喜欢，不是很喜欢 C++ 委员会在很多事情上使用深奥数字的程度。有人会说，哦，好吧，我们应该问问 SG16 那是什么。如果你不在 C++ 委员会，SG16 对你来说就没有意义。
And it's just like a series of random letters and numbers. That sentence is a lot more accessible if you say oh we should ask the text and unicode study group what that means or even just like the text study group what that means um and like even the name of the c++ committee wg21 you know people send an email about like something, something WG21, like just say C++ for the C++ committee. And, you know, we do use paper numbers for a lot of things and the numbers are useful. Like it's super useful to have like a reference number for stuff like papers. But one of the common, the common requests whenever there's some discussion about a paper, if somebody doesn't put the title of the paper in the email subject line or they don't mention the title of the paper when they're talking about it, somebody will almost inevitably be like, what paper are we talking about? I don't know what that number references.
这就像是一系列随机的字母和数字。如果你说“哦，我们应该问问文本和统一码研究小组那是什么”，或者甚至只是像“文本研究小组那是什么”，那句话就会更容易理解。而且，甚至 C++ 委员会的名字 WG21，你知道，人们发送一封关于什么的电子邮件，关于某某 WG21，直接说 C++ 或 C++ 委员会就行了。而且，你知道，我们在很多事情上确实使用论文编号，这些数字很有用。就像为论文之类的事物拥有一个参考编号超级有用。但其中一个常见的，每当对一篇论文进行讨论时的常见请求是，如果有人没有在电子邮件主题行中写上论文的标题，或者他们在谈论论文时没有提及论文标题，几乎不可避免地会有人说：我们在谈论哪篇论文？我不知道那个数字指的是什么。
I don't know what the subject is that we're discussing. And does it mean you have to be a little bit more verbose to expand these things out sure like typing library evolution instead of l-e-w-g like yeah that it's a few more characters um but like i i usually i usually don't mind those extra characters it's also fine too because co-pilot's gonna be here soon for just our regular text and we're not going to have to type anything. Yeah. I wonder,
我不知道我们正在讨论的主题是什么。这是否意味着你必须更啰嗦一点来把这些事情展开来说？当然，像输入 library evolution 而不是 L-E-W-G，是的，这多了几个字符，但通常我并不介意多出来的那些字符。这也很好，因为 Copilot 很快就会为我们日常的文本服务，我们不需要再打任何字了。对。我想知道，
are we so hostile to copilot because copilot is actually a bad idea or because like some part of us deep down is like, Oh, only humans can do this. And like, there's some deep down guttural response. That's like, Oh, we got to protect our job security.
我们对 Copilot 如此敌视，是因为 Copilot 实际上是个糟糕的主意，还是因为我们内心深处的某个部分在想，哦，只有人类才能做到这一点，并且内心深处有一种本能的反应，那就是，哦，我们要保护我们的工作安全？
Nah. Well, my reaction is just, I mean, it's the same reaction that I have to, you know, regular society and algorithms. It's like, oh, we're going to train this AI to do this based on the last 30 years of data. Well, let's take a look back and see how humans did for the last 30 years. And the answer is terribly. And so we're going to train these AIs to have all the embedded bias and prejudice and oppression, all that stuff. In their defense though, I saw,
不。好吧，我的反应只是，我的意思是，这和我对普通社会和算法的反应是一样的，哦，我们要根据过去 30 年的数据来训练这个 AI 来做这件事。好吧，让我们回过头来看看人类在过去 30 年里做得怎么样。答案是糟糕透顶。所以我们要训练这些 AI 让他们拥有所有嵌入的偏见、偏见和压迫，所有这些东西。不过为他们辩护一下，我看到过，
what's the name of the Timnit, the AI bias researcher who was fired from Google recently? The one with the paper? Yeah. I do not know that individual's name. But yes, I know. Yeah. I think it's, hang on, hang on, hang on. I'll look it up.
那个叫什么名字的蒂姆尼特（Timnit），最近被谷歌解雇的 AI 偏见研究员？写过那篇论文的人？是的。我不知道那个人的名字。但是是的，我知道。是的，我想是，等等，等等，等等。我去查一下。
I'll look it up. I know it. I just can't pronounce it. Timnit, Timnit, Ge on. I'll look it up. I'll look it up. I know it. I just can't pronounce it. Timnit, Timnit, Gebru. I'm sure I'm butchering that. And I'm terribly sorry. She tweeted something mentioning the fact that GitHub Copilot happened to cite one of her papers on AI bias, like very prominently cited in one of the pages on their site that described how it worked. And her remark was something like, hey, you know,
我去查一下。我知道。我只是发不出那个音。蒂姆尼特，蒂姆尼特，Ge on。我去查一下。我去查一下。我知道。我只是发不出那个音。蒂姆尼特，蒂姆尼特·盖布鲁（Timnit Gebru）。我确信我把名字读砸了。我深表歉意。她发了一条推文，提到 GitHub Copilot 恰好引用了她关于 AI 偏见的一篇论文，在她网站上描述其工作原理的其中一个页面上非常显眼地引用了。她的评论大致是，嘿，你知道，
this paper got me fired from one company and there's another company that's, you know, citing it. So at the very least, I think they're aware of that. And while we are, you know, trashing on GitHub Copilot a bit, I do feel that we're perhaps being a little bit unfair. I mean, I think it is a very cool technology and a lot of people have put a ton of work into it. And I think that there is a lot of potential there. I saw an amazing talk a few years ago about this thing that I think was called like angelic programming. And the idea was that like you would write and somehow an expression of constraints or something or requirements. And then like the programming language or the system would figure out what the code was supposed to do based on that um and and so like like it's not that i think that this is a bad idea it's just that i think that there's a lot of um of challenges and open questions uh and potential for for abuse and harm under the hood here. Like the whole licensing question around it really scares me.
这篇论文让我被一家公司解雇了，而现在有另一家公司在引用它。所以至少我认为他们是意识到这一点的。当我们（你知道）对 GitHub Copilot 进行一些猛烈抨击时，我确实觉得我们可能有点不太公平。我的意思是，我认为这是一项非常酷的技术，很多人为此付出了大量的工作。而且我认为这里面有很大的潜力。几年前我听过一个精彩的演讲，讲的是一个我认为被称为天使编程（angelic programming）的东西。这个想法是，你编写某种约束或类似要求或需求的表达式。然后编程语言或系统就会根据这些弄清楚代码应该做什么，
And maybe it shouldn't, maybe like I'm overreacting, but I think like we're sort of in untested waters there for what exactly that means. And yeah, like the quality of what you'll get out of it, you know, it's probably been trained in a lot of code that contains security vulnerabilities and, you know, memory safety violations and stuff like that. And so you've got to think about that.
所以就像，并不是我认为这是一个坏主意，只是我认为这里面有很多挑战、未解的问题，以及幕后被滥用和造成危害的潜力。比如围绕它的整个许可问题真的把我吓坏了。也许它不应该，也许我反应过度了，但我认为对于这到底意味着什么，我们现在可以说是处于未知的领域。是的，比如你从中学到的代码质量，你知道，它可能已经在包含安全漏洞、内存安全违规等大量代码上进行了训练。所以你必须考虑这一点。
But that said, I mean, I think tools like this are probably the future of how we'll program. And so, of course, you know, this being the first big one to be launched, you know, it's going to have some problems. And we're going to probably all be skeptical about it for a while. And probably it'll lead to some, you know, some bad PRs and some mistakes. But who knows where it'll be like 10, 20 years from now. I mean, I think it's a super smart move by GitHub to invest in something like this.
话虽如此，我的意思是，我认为这样的工具可能是我们未来编程方式的未来。所以，当然，既然这是推出的第一个大型产品，它就会有一些问题。而且我们可能都会对它持怀疑态度一段时间。它可能还会导致一些糟糕的公关和一些错误。但谁知道它在 10 年、20 年后会是什么样呢。我的意思是，我认为 GitHub 投资这样东西是一个超级聪明的举动。
I think it's really brilliant usage of their platform and the data that they have available through their platform. I would, I really would like to see them, though, spend some cycles making GitHub search not so terrible. Like, I get it, cool, you guys made an AI that can pair program with me. That's great. But all that I would really like is to be able to search for C++ expressions on GitHub that are not simple identifiers and get coherent results. Like, please, pretty please, I would like to be able to search for,
我认为这是对他们的平台以及他们通过平台获得的可用数据的真正精彩的使用。不过，我真的很希望看到他们花一些周期让 GitHub 搜索不那么糟糕。听着，我知道，很酷，你们制作了一个可以和我进行结对编程的 AI。这太棒了。但我真正想要的是能够在 GitHub 上搜索不是简单标识符的 C++ 表达式并获得连贯的结果。拜托，求求你了，我希望能搜索，
you know, some C++ expression that contains non-alphanumeric characters and have it not just filter out all the non-alphanumeric characters. Yeah. So please, please, folks. And do some, like, deduplication because, like, inevitably you search for something and then, like, there's 40 pages of, like, you know, page number one to page number 40 is all the same library that's just been forked a thousand times. Um, you know, this, this actually makes me think of, um, so my, my, my predecessor and library evolution, the former library evolution chair, Titus Winters,
你知道的，包含非字母数字字符的 C++ 表达式，并且不要让它只过滤掉所有非字母数字字符。是的。所以，求求你们了，伙计们。做一些去重，因为，不可避免地，你搜索某些东西，然后，从第 1 页到第 40 页都是同一个库，只是被 fork 了上千次。嗯，这，这实际上让我想到了，嗯，所以，我的，我的前任库演变主席蒂图斯·温特斯（Titus Winters），
um, he's a huge believer in, uh, in software engineering tooling. Um, I'd say he's one of the leading voices and advocates for the power of tools and automation in software engineering and how that can change how you write code. So the basic premise is like, hey, making breaking changes are hard. But imagine if we had tools that could automatically, you know, refactor code so that we could make breaking changes. Or, you know, evaluating how, what the impact of the change will be is hard. So imagine if we had, you know, tools that gave us great insight and visibility into our code bases. And so at Google, they have this code search engine, which from every time I've seen it been used has just been absolutely fabulous.
嗯，他是软件工程工具的坚定信仰者。我想说他是软件工程中工具和自动化力量的主要声音和倡导者之一，以及这如何改变你编写代码的方式。所以基本前提是，比如，进行破坏性更改是很难的。但想象一下，如果我们有能够自动重构代码以进行破坏性更改的工具。或者，你知道，评估更改的影响将是困难的。所以想象一下，如果我们有能够为我们的代码库提供巨大洞察力和可见性的工具。所以在谷歌，他们有这个代码搜索引擎，从我每次看到它使用的情况来看，绝对是棒极了。
And every now and then on the C++ committee, there's been a time when the committees ask some question like, you know, well, it would be nice if we could do X, but, you know, if we did that, maybe there'd be these edge cases that we'd have to worry about. Or like, you know, maybe a better example, like, let's deprecate X. And then somebody's like, oh, but X is still used. And then like, how do you disprove that? And then inevitably, one of the Google people on the committee will go start typing in their keyboard and they'll be like, I just searched our entire code base and I found 100 uses of X.
每隔一段时间，在 C++ 委员会上就会出现这样的时候，委员会会问一些问题，比如，嗯，如果我们能做 X 会很好，但是，如果我们那样做了，也许会有我们需要担心的这些边缘情况。或者像，你知道，也许一个更好的例子，比如，让我们废弃 X。然后有人会说，哦，但是 X 仍在被使用。然后就像，你如何反驳这一点？然后不可避免地，委员会中的一位谷歌员工会开始在键盘上打字，他们会说：我刚刚搜索了我们的整个代码库，我发现了 100 处 X 的使用。
And relative to the size of our code base, that means that it's essentially not used anywhere. And just that ability of being able... Like, imagine that you're in a meeting talking about some design decision that you're going to make. And just imagine being able to go and just search, like, the code base... Like, not all code in the world, but like a representative size of code to be able to search it and answer some query about, like, how frequently is this pattern used? How frequently is this function called with this type of arguments? Like just imagine being able to get answers to that very rapidly. It would
相对于我们代码库的规模来说，这意味着它基本上在任何地方都没有被使用。仅仅是那种能够……想象一下，你在一个会议上讨论你将要做出的一些设计决定。只要想象一下能够去搜索，比如代码库……不是世界上所有的代码，而是能够搜索代表性规模的代码，并回答关于诸如以下查询：这个模式的使用频率是多少？这个函数使用这种参数类型的调用频率是多少？只要想象能够非常迅速地得到这些答案。它将
totally change how we would make decisions about software evolution. Yeah, that's a super powerful tool. Amazon has something similar. I don't think it's as polished as Google's, but. NVIDIA has something similar called Envy Grok. And yeah, it's not as polished as Google. But what I really want is I really want the open source version of that. And there used to be some open, Google used to run some open version of this called like Google Code Search or something. Maybe it's still around.
彻底改变我们对软件演进做出决策的方式。是的，那是一个超级强大的工具。亚马逊也有类似的东西。我不认为它像谷歌的那么精炼，但是。英伟达有一个类似的东西叫 Envy Grok。是的，它不如谷歌的那么精炼。但我真正想要的是我真的想要它的开源版本。以前有一些开源的，谷歌过去运行过这个东西的一个开源版本，叫做谷歌代码搜索（Google Code Search）或类似的名字。也许它还在。
I seem to recall using it at some point in the past. But what I really want, you know, ultimately what we really want is we want to be able to go and search through GitHub and like do these queries on GitHub. But it's just not really possible and feasible today with the limitations of their search API. Yeah. Yep. Well, so wait, I'll say one more thing, and then we need to figure out what to call this little 30-minute episode. Uh, so I tried to sign up for this co-pilot, because what I want to see, if I type into
我隐约记得过去在某个时候用过它。但我真正想要的，最终我们真正想要的是，我们希望能够去搜索 GitHub，并在 GitHub 上执行这些查询。但以他们搜索 API 的局限性来看，今天这实际上是不可能也是不可行的。是的。好吧，等等，我再说一件事，然后我们需要弄清楚这个 30 分钟的小插曲该叫什么名字。所以，我试着注册这个 Copilot，因为我想看到的是，如果我输入到
my C++ program a comment that says, sum the elements of this vector, put a little pointy arrow to the vector above. Will it give me a for loop or will it give me a std accumulate? That's what I want to know. And if it gives me a std accumulate, sign me up. I'll have code.
我的 C++ 程序中有一个注释，说“对这个向量的元素求和”，并在上面的向量上画一个小尖箭头。它会给我一个 for 循环，还是会给我一个 std accumulate？这就是我想知道的。如果它给我一个 std accumulate，算我一个。我会有代码的。
I'll have this. What about range-based i'll have what about range based for loop is range based for loop acceptable no oh no you said you said an accumulation pattern yeah okay i meant like i was thinking like more for each pattern thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我会有这个的。基于范围的怎么样？我会，基于范围的 for 循环怎么样？基于范围的 for 循环可以接受吗？不，哦，不，你刚才说的是，你刚才说的是累加模式。是的，好吧，我的意思是，我更倾向于像 for each 模式。谢谢收听，希望你们喜欢，祝大家有美好的一天。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。